[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous ces paléo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux alors l'actualité du jour c'est
évidemment le projet trine axe qui prend
finalement son envol littéralement
puisque à l'heure où vous regardez cette
vidéo est bien cédric et probablement
dans l'avion en train de voler vers
l'afrique du sud pour venir nous
rejoindre et partir sur le terrain dans
le karoo avec nous alors pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas le projet trine accès
bien je vous mettrais un lien vers la
page
ulule du projet où tout est décrit donc
le projet trina que c'est une
collaboration entre
nous-mêmes à l'université de
witwatersrand à johannesbourg et cédric
jurassique de la chaîne du même nom qui
nous a aidés finalement a récolté une
assez importante quantité d'argent afin
d'amener les étudiants de l'université
du vide bathurst rende sur le terrain
pour les former à la paléontologie et
donc le deal est bien c'est que si on
arrivait à récolter tout l'argent est
bien on l'emmènerait lui aussi sur le
terrain pour qu'il nous fasse des belles
vidéos et voilà ça y est ça va se faire
ça commence demain on est tous hyper
excitées ici à l'université et j'espère
j'espère que ça va vraiment bien marché
et qu'on va faire une super
collaboration en tout cas voilà ça y est
ça commence
c'est le moment le projet trine axe
c'est parti l'autre actualité c'est
cette vidéo cette vidéo qui a été postée
par le docteur jesse kristjansson qui
est astronome et qui nous a fait une
magnifique vidéo en fait une infographie
ou le temps qu'a vécu les robes les
dinosaures le temps qu'ont vécu les
dinosaures pardon est représenté sous la
forme de la distance parcourue par la
terre dans la galaxie et ça je trouve ça
carrément trop classe et bombe à la
vidéo n'existe qu'en anglais alors du
coup je vais vous la faire en français
donc je vais vous la traduire en direct
voilà donc c'est alors ça c'est la
version la plus la plus à jour parce que
je l'avais posté sur facebook cette
vidéo mais c'était une version 7 est une
version qui n'était pas tout
totalement à jour puisqu'elle avait mis
un plésiosaure en disant que c'était un
dinosaure et ce n'est pas un dinosaure
vous avez raison docteur christiane
scène donc voilà je vais vous la
dérouler je vais vous la déroulait en
direct je vais couper le son pour pas
que c'est un terrain pour pas que ça que
ça parasite le micro et jeu on va je
vais vous la traduire en direct ça
commence maintenant
saviez vous que les dinosaures ont vécu
à l'autre bout de la galaxie
voici une vue d'artiste delà de notre
voie lactée vue du dessus
alors bon si on peut dire vu du dessus
donc voici où se situe le soleil dans la
galaxie le soleil prend 250 millions
d'années pour faire le tour du centre de
notre voie lactée
la dernière fois qu'il s'est trouvé là
où il se trouve aujourd'hui c'était
d'autres y a six qui lie à entre 2 152
et 200 millions d'années quand les tout
premiers dinosaures ont vécu comme
l'eoraptor après vient la période
jurassique qui dure 55 millions d'années
le crétacé entre 145 et 66 millions
d'années ou avec huyghe nos dons et
giganotosaurus le crétacé inférieur
waouh ça va vite le crétacé inférieur
donc a eu lieu littéralement de l'autre
côté de la galaxie donc en plus ça vaut
le coup de faire une pause puisque vous
voyez donc on a démarré ici c'est là où
se trouve la terre aujourd'hui c'est là
où elle était au trias et donc la terre
elle depuis le trias en fait elle a
parcouru tout ça donc l élite donc au
crétacé en fait elle est littéralement
de l'autre côté de la galaxie par
rapport à là où elle se trouvait au
trias et aussi du coût par rapport à là
où elle se trouve aujourd'hui voici où a
vécu velociraptor voici où a vécu
tyrannosaurus rex
donc il est il ya 65 millions d'années
et pouf l'extinction crétacé tertiaire
il ya 65 millions d'années donc 66
millions d'années mais bon elle est
astrophysicienne lé pa paléontologues
elle sait pas que c'est 66 millions
d'années savent à quoi ça va on lui
pardonne donc c'est l'évolution des
mammifères qui qui a eu lieu depuis 66
millions d'années jusqu'à maintenant la
grande radiation évolutif donc voici où
se trouve homo sapiens donc tout à la
fin si on peut là c'est allé très vite
ça va vraiment très très vite voilà
trois cent cinquante mille ans jusqu'à
aujourd'hui bon homo sapiens et 300
mille ans c'est pareil à l'epa
paléoanthropologue ses 300 millions
trois cent cinquante mille ans elle
anticipe déjà la découverte du prochain
fossiles j'ai envie de dire donc voilà
et on est donc le soleil prend 250
millions d'années pour faire le tour de
la galaxie et la question c'est à quoi
la terre va t'elle ressembler dans 250
millions d'années quand elle reviendra
au même endroit voilà et moi je trouve
cette infographie vraiment trop classe
tellement classe d'ailleurs qu'on va la
remettre
parce que bah finalement c'est une
manière extrêmement élégante et
extrêmement
extrêmement visuel de présenter le temps
géologiques au final est extrêmement pas
vu aussi parce que finalement les temps
géologiques ya plein de gens qui utilise
la métaphore de l'horloge pour les
présenter et c'est vrai que la métaphore
de l'horloge à la ce problème que bah
ouais visuellement visuellement si ça ça
marche pas bah vous savez pas trop
comment vous en sortir quoi moi je pars
expérience avec mes étudiants les le
visuel de l'horloge ils marchent pas des
masses voilà et donc ça ça je trouve que
c'est vraiment beaucoup plus visuel est
beaucoup plus impactant que que le
visuel de l'horloge et saha le et ça le
bon goût de faire la connexion entre
l'astronomie et la paléontologie ce qui
est quand même une opportunité qu'on n'a
pas qu'on n'a pas tous les jours
bon après voilà les il ya des micros
inexactitudes comme le fait qu'elle
utilise 65 millions d'années pour
l'extinction crétacé tertiaire et le
fait qu'elle place l'origine d'homo
sapiens à 250 mille ans bon on sait pas
on sait pas ce que seront les dates dans
la prochaine charte stratigraphique si
ça se trouve un jour on reviendra à 65
millions d'années et le prochain
fossiles d'homo sapiens archaïque
repoussera l'origine d'homo sapiens a350
1000 ans qui sait mais en tout cas voilà
le moi je trouve qui a su que c'est
suffisamment exact pour être montrées et
que c'est suffisamment visuels pour être
abusés j'ai envie de dire pour qu'on en
abuse voilà avant de vous quitter vous
avez peut-être remarqué le regain
d'activité de la chaîne très récemment
donc on a publié quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de vidéos
ces deux dernières semaines et ça va
devoir se ralentir parce que justement
on s'en va avec cédric jurassique sur le
terrain donc il y aura pas de vidéo ou
peut-être une ou deux vidéos qui sait il
y aura pas de 1 jour à fos il y aura pas
de paléo news pendant deux semaines
parce qu'on va être sur le terrain et
qu'on va pas avoir d'accès à internet ou
très très peu d'accès à internet
mais ne vous en faites pas on sera pas
mort et on mettra plein de vidéos quand
on reviendra avec cédric jurassique
justement donc ne vous inquiétez pas si
vous voyez que l'activité de la chaîne
baisse dans les prochaines semaines
c'est pas qu'on vous a oublié c'est
juste qu'on n'est pas là voilà donc
merci à tous d'avoir suivi cette vidéo
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner pour ne
rien manquer d'anciens et à très bientôt
sur notre chaîne